yo quiero saludar en este momento a
paulina astros ahí es abogada doctora en
ciencias políticas y sociales abogada
buen día gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 le pregunto la
importancia de este plebiscito en chile
en un contexto de protestas y también
descontento social además le pregunto
qué votarían exactamente los chilenos el
día de hoy
como estas buenos días raúl la
importancia es máxima
estamos hablando de el dar la
posibilidad dentro de un sistema
democrático a la ciudadanía a expresarse
si es que quiero no cambiar la actual
constitución que nos rige y además
elegir cuál sería el órgano encargado en
caso de ganar el apruebo y que estaría
dedicado durante al menos nueve meses
con posibilidad de prórroga de tres
veces más es decir un año en redactar el
nuevo texto constitucional por lo tanto
es un hecho histórico el último
plebiscito que nosotros vivimos fue en
1988 cuando se le dijo que no a la
continuación de pinochet en el poder y
ahora lo que estamos votando es
justamente cambiar la constitución y que
de manera participativa inclusiva en que
la ciudadanía elija en democracia a
aquellos representantes para dictar un
nuevo texto constitucional
ahora en caso de que gane si para
modificar esta constitución cuáles
serían los pasos a seguir y cuánto
duraría de además cómo sería el proceso
para modificarla
se nos van a entregar digo se nos van a
entregar o yo todavía no voy a votar se
nos van a entregar dos papeletas la
primera en que nos van a preguntar si
aprobamos o rechazamos el tener una
nueva constitución y al mismo tiempo se
nos va a entregar una segunda papeleta
en que nos van a preguntar cuál es el
órgano que queremos que sea el encargado
de redactar la y hay dos alternativas
una de la convención mixta lo que
significa que el 50 por ciento serían
parlamentarios actuales en ejercicio que
ellos determinaría según las fuerzas
políticas en el congreso y el otro 50%
sería elegido por la ciudadanía por
candidatos que se presentarían en
elecciones en el mes de abril de ganar
la segunda opción que se llama la
convención constitucional
aquí el 100% de los candidatos o sea los
constituyentes serían elegidos
democráticamente por el pueblo y esto
sería en el mes de abril por lo tanto
tenemos una elección en el mes de abril
en el caso de la flor
luego viene el período en que los
constituyentes deben ya empezar a
trabajarse a convención mixta sea
convención constitucional y una vez que
tengan el texto está lo que se llama el
plebiscito de salida es decir nuevamente
los van a llamar a las urnas pero esta
vez para que digamos aceptados o no
aceptamos el texto redactado por el
órgano que estuvo a cargo durante un año